um in today's legal minute we're  learning about pool safety laws eric  palacios from eric palacios and  associates the sponsors of this segment  tells us more  i'm eric palacios welcome to the legal  minute this week's question is what are  pool safety laws in nevada number one  you must have a self-closing gate and  this must operate properly  it's a good recommendation to also have  a separate enclosure if you have small  children  it's always important to have an adult  supervising small children  and finally be very careful with doggy  doors crawling children can easily go  out of doggy doors and drown if you have  guests with small children you're always  responsible for their safety we hope  everyone has a safe summer we'll see you  next week here on the legal minute  and if you'd like more information you  can give eric palacios and associates a  call at  the website at 702-444-7777  las vegas now we'll be right back